what I'd like you to input is this
general quadratic this general quadratic
that we wrote down ax squared plus BX
plus C just pop it in up the top write
it exactly as you can see it there and
bless you if you're right ax squared
plus BX plus C it should prompt you
you've used it before you've reasonably
comfortable with this it should plump to
you hey do you want to add some sliders
you know how you're like a B and C what
on earth of those so can you hit that
and then you'll get these three sliders
we'll look more or less identical to
what I've got there I'm just gonna give
you a second to do that now once you've
got your x squared plus BX plus C what
I'd love you to do is change a B and C
so that you can see I've got not just
any random numbers
I've got particular numbers that have
chosen and I'll let you work out why it
is oh I had to change a thing sorry
a is wrong let's - oh I need to make
this a bit bigger let's let me get
bigger numbers please xx there we go now
we're talking okay
so clicking show of hands who's at least
got ax squared plus BX plus C their
hands up and you've got sliders keep
your hand up yep okay that's fine even
if you're still fiddling with the
numbers no big deal
can you have a look with me and what
we've got on the screen right here is my
general quadratic and hopefully as we
were doing this you like I'm familiar
enough with quadratics that I knew
roughly this is the parabola that I
would get let me zoom in just a little
bit so you can see there we go there's
negative 2 there's negative 3 these are
the zeros we would call them the
x-intercepts I think that was mentioned
earlier right the x-intercepts of this
parabola are the same as the zeros right
now as we pointed out have a look at my
value of ay right watch what happens as
we change that let's just hit play on it
there we go
but where's it going oh it's just gone
to state it's really state let me zoom
out a little bit there we go okay now as
we change this value of a you've got a
weird crazy polynomial happening let's
go that away there we go
right this crazy quadratic changing
places or like kind of thing right but
interestingly you've got 3 15 or 18
which are the values we started with
right so you can see I've got my
negative 2 and my negative 3 there and
what's great with this is I can actually
take these calculations a B and C which
produce this graph and I can compare
them to what we have just determined
right alpha plus beta these two things
they should always equal what's this
result that I've written here they alpha
must be always equal minus B over it and
I can just write that into desmos right
I can say - and you'll have to go over
to your alphabetical keyboard to get B
and a but I'm gonna go over there get my
B and then if I hit division I can put
in minus B over a and it very handily
gives you an answer negative 5 just like
we verified before ok we can also do
this not just with the sum of roots but
also the product is so what should I
input down here what calculation should
I get desmos to do Cierre thank you so
I'm going to put C
and divide and then hey and
unsurprisingly we get six like we saw
before negative two times negative three
equals six and the real genius of being
able to explore this is we can fiddle
with these numbers right so for instance
if I took C over there and we made it a
bit lower so I've got 18 at the moment
I'm gonna just drop it down like so and
choose a scale that's a little more
usable for you guys okay so have a look
I've got a value of C as 12 right now
now we have not factorized this at this
instant right but have a look I've
chosen this value because I've got some
nice whole numbers here let me zoom in a
little bit closer there we go I've got
negative 1 and negative 4 right so when
you get the sum of roots what's the
result have a look it's right there just
calculate for you it's negative 5 hey
wait a second negative 5 isn't that what
I got before negative 5 isn't that what
I got before but I have totally
different roots I've totally different
and they still add it to the same thing
why is that have a look at the result
right alpha plus beta
bica waiting because what minus B over a
so it depends on B it depends on a does
it depend on C the answer is no what we
would say is it is independent of C so
in fact go take your value of C right
and this is why I asked you to have a
look at yourself good fiddle around with
it change its value and you can see
you'll get completely different roots
but they'll always add up to whatever
value it is that they currently state
for me it's negative 5 for you it might
be something else because you might have
different values for a B and C okay and
you can get weird numbers right like I
I'm gonna take C and put it on something
awkward like say oops sorry
uncoordinated I'm gonna put on something
awkward like say 11 right Oh a bad aim
there there we go
all right now when you get this value 11
right if we went through with a problem
like this you would have some trouble
factorizing this wouldn't you right why
would we have trouble factorizing
something which has an 11 on the end
massive
yeah look at look at these x-intercepts
you notice they don't land on a whole
number and the reason why is if what you
got given what I gave you at the
beginning was 3 x squared plus 15 X plus
11
what would you start thinking you're
like all I need to think of a pair of
numbers that adds to this and multiplies
to that but you're like wait a second
multiplies to 11 11 is not just a number
it's a prime number so you're like great
if it's not 1 and 11 I don't know what
it is so you've got to go to the
quadratic formula and you get weird
you've got thirds in your zeros here
right so gross but nonetheless despite
how messy looking this is what's the
summer it's still negative 5 doesn't
care because the sum of roots is
independent of C okay go fiddle with V
from in it if you fiddle with me what
happens you're gonna get a change in
your parabola right yeah things like
this B is the number that we're just
slide around B and see what you get
slide it around
now what I'm really interested in is
take B and make it a little bit lower
maybe a little bit lower so I'm gonna
and I wonder if you can watch me here
right what I want you to do is make it
low enough whoops
sorry I've got bad aim with my fingers
here make it low enough that your
parabola goes up above the x-axis this
is now me getting out why do we care
about this why is this interesting
okay so hopefully you've got something
it looks vaguely like this right now
having a look at these numbers here
let's make see something a little bit
neater source let's see gross
no I'm always gonna get gross numbers
here yeah whatever that's why I'm
interested by looking at this right
because I'm getting a sum of roots it's
that looks to me like negative two and
two thirds
okay I'm getting a product of roots
which looks to me like four and
one-third okay a product of zeros I
should say why is this weird
can anyone point out to me why it might
be unusual that the sum of the zeros
would be this and the product of the
zeros would be this so I don't notice
anything weird about this where are the
zeros I don't see any zeros do you like
the zeros are meant to be where this
graph intersects with the x-axis the
x-intercepts right you're like I don't
have any zeros if I gave you this thing
here 3x squared plus 8x plus 13 right I
want you to think back right we have a
way of determining before we even start
solving this we have a way of
determining the letter D whether
something will have zeros or not what's
it called
it's the discriminant right and the
discriminant is b squared minus 4ac now
if you're like me you look at these
numbers you're like Chris I don't want
to work this out thankfully you're
sitting in front of a calculator right
put the next line in and let's calculate
the discriminant on this guy right
you're gonna need to put in B what's the
next part B squared and then minus 4ac
thank you very much
now you have a different parabola on
your screen to mine probably at this
point right but hopefully we can all
agree that if you've made your parabola
something that's above the x-axis what
do you notice about the value of your
discriminant it's negative I've got
negative 92 it's really negative even if
you've got something like negative 1 or
negative 1/4 right the point is this
discriminant it belongs underneath the
square root of the quadratic formula
you're like wait a second not meant to
get negative numbers underneath the
square root and your quadratic form are
just kind of explodes in your face
that's why there are no zeros and yet
despite there being no zeros apparently
I can still add them and get something
sensible and apparently I can still
multiply them and get something sensible
let me show you why